la réserve initiale d'oxygène était de
96 heures il reste maintenant moins de
40 heures d'oxygène à bord du Titan se
submersible disparu dans l'Atlantique
avec 5 personnes à son bord dimanche
c'est engin exploité par Ocean gate
expédition un morceau de descente vers
les pales du Titanic situé quand même
après 4000 mètres de profondeur et une
heure et 45 minutes plus tard il
disparaissait plus de communication les
garde côtière américaine et canadienne
affirment travailler en surface et en
profondeur pour retrouver l'engin et ses
occupants il en navire français à talent
et son robot autonome doivent arriver en
renfort demain d'ailleurs l'équipage
arrive par avion ce soir à Montréal
entre-temps l'opération s'avère très
complexe
speaking
et la Garde côtière américaine quand
même révélé les noms des cinq disparus
on les voit ici à l'écran parmi ceux-ci
on retrouve Henri Paul-Henri norjolet un
français spécialiste du Titanic
explorateur etc 35 reprises sur le site
de l'EHPAD il nous avait accordé une
entrevue l'année dernière à l'occasion
du 11e anniversaire du naufrage du
Titanic d'ailleurs on va vous présenter
un extrait de cet entretien dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord un
entretien réalisé un plutôt un peu
plutôt aujourd'hui avec son ami éditeur
Mathieu Johan
monsieur Joanne merci d'être en 24 60 ce
soir merci d'être avec nous pour parler
de votre ami Monsieur narjolais vous
êtes son éditeur et attaché de presse
c'est vous qui l'avez convaincu de
publier les récits de sa passion et de
son expertise dans les profondeurs du
Titanic l'année dernière en 2021
n'est-ce pas
tout à fait ça a été ça a été un petit
défi puisque quand j'ai appelé
Paul-Henry à l'époque pour pour imaginer
écrire ses souvenirs autour de l'épave
du Titanic d'abord il m'a dit non et
puis quand je lui ai dit que je que mes
enfants étaient absolument passionnés
par cette histoire c'est des intrigués
beaucoup je lui ai dit pendant riche
j'aimerais être un super papa est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que vous accepteriez
si
c'est mes enfants qui vous le demandent
et il m'a dit si c'est pour vos enfants
alors ok je vais le faire le fasse ce
désir de transmettre dans le fond c'est
découverte cette quête de vérité autour
de ce grand mystère pour ne pas dire
fantasme Titanic n'est-ce pas
c'est quelque chose qui l'intriguait
beaucoup je pense que dans l'histoire de
paul-hen angelet qui a quand même connu
des dizaines d'expéditions qui a connu
beaucoup beaucoup d'aventures dans sa
vie finalement il a il a consacré
jusqu'ici une trentaine d'années
à ce paquebot de légende et je crois que
ne voulait jamais jusqu'à présent que ça
s'arrête il rêvait d'une chose c'est de
percer tous les mystères du Titanic il y
a beaucoup de beaucoup de choses qu'il
voulait encore savoir et malgré qu'il
est remonté des milliers d'objets à la
surface malgré malgré ces trentaine ça
trentaine de plongées sur les pages
c'était passionnel entre lui et le
paquebot donc
cette plongée qu'il vient d'effectuer
encore touristique cette fois était une
manière pour lui de partager encore avec
des touristes cette fois sa passion pour
le paquebot de légende parce qu'il était
intarissable sur ce sur ce sujet on
pouvait commencer à dîner à 20h et
se coucher le lendemain matin avec ton
Henri c'était et dingue ce livre c'est
144 pages et ça se parcourt avec
vraiment avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt on a de découvrir ce qu'il va
découvrir mais quelque chose va saisi
aujourd'hui à la relecture au moins des
premières pages de l'ouvrage lors de sa
première descente son premier récit 25
juillet
1987 il y a un incident de sa première
descente il y a quelque chose qui
accroche mais il garde le calme et s'en
sortent bien il dit et je le cite à la
joie d'avoir atteint notre but de cette
première plongée semelle la tristesse
devant l'évidence du drame et il dit
avoir vu au ressenti tout ce qui a pu se
passer dans le drame c'était sa première
plongée
plusieurs fois risquer sa vie au cours
de ces expéditions il en parlait avec
beaucoup de légèreté beaucoup de calme
beaucoup d'humilité aussi il l'a
toujours dit que l'océan la mer était
était plus puissante que nous et que et
que ce cette mère pouvait faire une
bouchée de nous en un instant si on
n'était pas vigilant attentif ça ne l'a
jamais empêché de poursuivre sa mission
et d'enchaîner les missions et
d'embarquer des gens avec lui dans ses
dans ses envies et de et de ramener
autant d'objets à la surface il a je
crois que
on parle beaucoup de ce sous-marin dont
il pouvait peut-être se méfier on lit
beaucoup ça dans la presse ce petit
sous-marin qu'il a emprunté là avec les
quelques les quelques personnes à bord
je pense que pendant oui s'il avait
senti le moindre danger en tout cas
avant de s'embarquer il n'y serait
jamais allé c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement prudent et d'extrêmement
instinctif alors on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'un accident d'un incident
plusieurs fois il nous a même raconté
une fois qu'en descendant avec une
équipe de de tournage le câble de la de
la caméra c'est enroulé sur une partie
métallique du Titanic et qu'il pensait
bien qu'il allait rester qu'il allait
être bloqué avec son équipage ils ont
réussi finalement à s'excire et
plusieurs fois
plusieurs fois Paul Henry a certainement
risqué sa vie il ne la d'ailleurs
certainement pas tout raconté pour ne
pas trop inquiéter ses proches mais ce
n'est jamais sans risque évidemment que
d'être un grand explorateur comme il
l'est donc il prenait la mesure des
risques il voulait toujours y retourner
et toujours dans l'ouvrage j'ai dit le
Titanic était le Graal des chasseurs
d'épaves pour ne pas dire les chasseurs
de trésors
et aujourd'hui comme il y a fait plus de
35 plongés
et qu'on espère le petit miracle au
moment où on se parle il reste encore
une quarantaine d'heures il y a tout
français avec un submersible capable
d'aller les secourir donc évidemment
tant que la vie et de l'espoir cela dit
il est quand même
est-ce que c'est une ironie du sort de
penser que lui qui a chassé une épave à
son tour maintenant il devient le sujet
de cette
de cette quête pour le retrouver
tout un destin je pense que je pense que
si je l'espère et nous l'espérons tous
si Paul-Henri est encore actuellement en
vie et
c'est beaucoup d'émotions pour nous de
que de dire cela mais je suis certain
qu'il est extrêmement rassurant et
protecteur pour ces passagers et pour
les gens qui l'ont embarqué et qu'il a
extrêmement confiance en ces gens qui la
côtoyé tout au long de sa vie et qui ont
qui aujourd'hui effectuent des
recherches pour le retrouver lui je
pense que Paul Henry est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement rassurant quand on se
retrouve dans une situation d'urgence
son expérience aussi son âge font que il
est certainement un sacré commandant à
bord de ce petit de ce petit vaisseau il
doit avoir hâte de remonter
ou qu'on vient de les rechercher
j'espère vraiment vraiment que les
recherches qui sont extraordinaires qui
sont extraordinairement menées par les
Américains par les Canadiens par les
Français par les Britanniques vont vont
pouvoir connaître une issue heureuse on
espère vraiment du fond du cœur pour sa
famille surtout pour hams son épouse oui
sa fille et l'ensemble de sa famille il
a fait vivre de grandes émotions à
différentes personnes dans le livre
toujours dans les profondeurs du Titanic
il raconte comment cette descente avec
base Goldwin celui qui a marché sur la
Lune lui a confié avoir vécu la plus
grande émotion après avoir marché sur la
Lune c'est dire les sensations fortes à
3000 mètres près de 4000 mètres sous
l'eau n'est-ce pas
oui il est complètement
à chaque fois qu'il nous parle du
Titanic Paul-Henri il allait il a les
étoiles qui s'allument dans les yeux et
puis et puis il est intarissable encore
une fois et puis il vous raconte le jour
où il a découvert cette valise qu'il a
remonté et il vous raconte que avec un
bras de son de son sous-marin il réussit
à entrouvrir une petite malle et qui a
une partition qui s'envole comme ça
comme dans l'air alors que c'est dans
l'eau que ça se passe il a des il a des
choses absolument magiques à partager
vous savez ce que je pense est pardonner
mon émotion mais c'est que les héros ne
meurent jamais est-ce qu'on espère tous
c'est que comme dans un bon vieux film à
la télévision au cinéma que le héros
réapparaisse à la fin de ce ce mauvais
scénario
Paul Henri il a il a tout du héros il a
tout du grand héros qu'on admire qu'on
écoute
qu'on a envie de serrer dans nos bras
qu'on aimerait avoir pour papa pour
grands-parents
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de rare et je
vraiment je
suis en union de penser avec sa famille
aujourd'hui pour leur dire de tout mon
cœur que ils ne sont pas seuls et que je
sais qu'il y a plein de gens qui
attendent le retour de Paul Henry sur la
terre ferme et je suis certain qu'il
sera capable de nous dire s'il revient
vous avez eu peur pas moi ah ouais parce
que il a
il nous a fait vivre
le Titanic il a redonné
presque une existence au passager avec
tous ces 5000 artefact sortie de l'eau
il a donné un sens à ce drame là d'une
certaine manière pour qu'on les oublie
jamais c'était un de ces objectifs
complètement il a cessé d'essayer de
retrouver notamment les familles de
passagers pour leur remettre les objets
pour transmettre pour leur expliquer
pour leur dire comment il avait
découvert ça à côté de quel autre objet
tout ça avait beaucoup de sens pour lui
il est anti-business d'ailleurs une
condition pour participer à ces travaux
de recherche c'était que les objets ne
soient jamais vendus aux enchères ne
soient jamais pendus pour en faire un
pour en faire un commerce juteux et
c'était très très important pour lui en
France à Cherbourg donc en Normandie se
tient une exposition permanente c'est la
seule d'ailleurs en Europe et cette
exposition était très précieuse pour
penderie parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
venait et on nous y sommes allés il y a
quelques mois encore ensemble il avait à
coeur de parler aux gens qui passaient
d'une chaussure qui se trouve en vitrine
qu'il avait remonté avec son bras
mécanique et son sous-marin et son avec
son équipe il était vraiment passionné
petit garçon
[Musique]
alors Mathieu Johan amis éditeur et
attaché de presse de Monsieur narjolais
on espère ce miracle merci beaucoup
merci merci pour lui merci
et l'année dernière en avril 2022 à
l'occasion du 110e anniversaire du
naufrage du tennis mais je me suis
entretenu avec Paul-Henry marjolais mais
il est surnommé aussi monsieur Titanic
mais pourquoi parce qu'il est considéré
comme un explorateur légendaire 35
missions sur les pages pendant 35 ans et
ce vendredi il devait recevoir une
médaille de l'Académie de la marine de
France on écoute cet extrait
vous avez voulu percer les mystères les
secrets du Titanic au cours de ces 35
dernières années et 35 expéditions dans
les profondeurs à plus de 3000 mètres
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
fasciné ou interpellé
aussi l'aspect de l'épave parce que bon
j'avais l'habitude de plonger sur des
épaves moins profondes qui ont un peu
toutes le même aspect avec des
concrétions marines etc mais le Titanic
lui évidemment aucune concrétion parce
que il y a pas la lumière qu'il faut
pour qu'elle puisse pousser et donc il a
un aspect très spécial avec ses ce que
les
d'ailleurs les Canadiens appellent les
rouillons qui sont des gens de
stalactites mais en
donner une couleur de rouille qui
pendent le long de l'épave et ça lui
donne un aspect très très particulier
vous écrivez le Titanic ne refera jamais
surface la vérité oui sur son naufrage
même si les légendes du Titanic sont
belles la réalité est plus puissante que
la fiction c'est qu'il faut il faut
séparer le vrai du faux dans l'histoire
du Titanic n'est-ce pas qu'est-ce qui
est vrai qu'est-ce qu'il faut
toujours alors il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui ne sont pas exactes comme
par exemple simplement le résultat de la
commission d'enquête qui disait qu'il y
avait une brèche de 100 mètres de long
et quand on a plongé on a évidemment pas
vu cette brèche parce que avec une
brèche pareil de 100 m de long je pense
que le Titanic aurait coulé aussi vite
que l'empresse
c'est-à-dire en 10 minutes or il a mis
deux heures et demie pour couler donc
c'était pas possible qu'il ait une
brèche aussi importante et on a
recherché cette brèche on a fini par la
détecter sans vraiment l'avoir de nos
propres yeux et ça ça fait partie des
choses qu'on a envie de savoir et
j'aimerais même encore aujourd'hui
approfondir cette question pour être sûr
que ce qu'on a détecté correspond à ce
que on pourrait voir les plus grandes
émotions que vous avez vécues au cours
de ces années je pense à cette montre en
or que vous avez pu remettre à une des
survivants
oui alors ça c'était un parce que il
s'est trouvé que un peu par hasard on
était à côté de justement de cette
montre en train de récupérer les objets
et avec un petit sentiment on a vu
qu'avec quelque chose qui brillait donc
c'était une montre on a retrouvé les
initiales de son propriétaire dessus et
ces initiales correspondaient à une
survivante qu'on connaissait déjà donc
qu'on avait déjà avec qui on avait parlé
et du coup le président de la compagnie
a décidé de remettre cette montre à
cette personne donc il a fabriqué un
petit coffret joli il était très
bricoleur et bombe bricoleur et on lui a
amené cette cette montre après qu'elle
ait été nettoyée pas par réparée parce
que c'était pas possible mais au moins
nettoyer et elle avait un aspect
particulier évidemment ça a beaucoup ému
cette personne qui s'appelait d'ailleurs
édité smile et on a gardé des liens avec
elle pendant plusieurs années et j'ai
retenu une chose lorsque vous avez
remonté une bouteille de champagne vous
avez dit on a on a récupéré un peu du
parfum du Titanic ce jour-là c'était
très émouvant donc
et ça j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire
parce que c'est la première fois de ma
vie que je effectivement que je
remontais une odeur qui venait du bateau
bon le champagne en plus c'est pas
forcément désagréable à se sentir et
ça m'est resté je pense que j'oublierai
jamais cette odeur ce jour-là parce
qu'au lieu de sentir le gasoil du bateau
en santé quand même une odeur bien plus
agréable et qui venait donc de 3800
mètres et qui avait à l'époque à peu
près 80 ans pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI